kikou même du chamois elle merry
christmas à tous aujourd'hui une
spéciale de l'art moderne de noël et
pour ça comme chaque jour que ce que je
fais ouh là là j'entends chez vous
j'appelle les boys et mais à la cuisse
mais ce mot buzz numéro un et lotois ou
speed couleurs j'adore ça c'est un magie
reste 56 12 bravo ça va super bien de
leurs modèles alors on y va on se met en
place
on commence par le classique je ne
répète pas bien sûr tu te retournes
agacé il est lara red carpet
on avance un petit peu qui sait qu'il
met des cadeaux à noël sous le sapin
c'est le lutin malin il est tout petit
il cherche à mettre des cadeaux aux
kills et rouky les coquins ou qu'il est
qu'aucun on veut l'attraper mais on n'y
arrive pas on n'y arrive pas voilà il
est là bravo méga de l'art moderne et
ensuite derrière mettre les cadeaux sous
le sapin cette année encore le sapin il
est comment il est fort et qu'est-ce qui
fait il agite ses boules et ses
guirlandes rona là on le regarde que
l'époux à cette année ce sapin ou qu'il
ait bouya jamais été aussi beau sapin et
ensuite qu'est ce qu'on a bien sûr le
paquet coquet lui il va se mettre sous
le sapin et il veut quoi qu'on ouvre le
paquet coquet où la vague des baux il
est beau en vrai moi en vrai moi je suis
là je le cas pas à regarder moi de
profil comme je suis bon je suis beau si
le dos qui veut montrer regardez
regardez up mais c'est pas qu'elle est
tellement bon qu'est ce qu'il faut faire
en bas c'est triste mais paul ii n'ayant
pas garder pour nous on bat le prix
voilà bravo chiboub de l'ère moderne
alors j'ai un autre petit cadeau pour
vous possèdent de leur modèle qui dit
noël dit père noël il est avec nous mais
bon être regardée comme il est beau l
open route du rock en fait quand toi
qu'est ce que j'avais dit pas dessus qu
après 18 heures oui qu'il est fou celui
là et père noël tu sais quoi je t'aime
tellement
j'ai envie d'offrir un cadeau mais quoi
en une route où flynn rose espérée par
hasard un bon vendeur de roses qui
serait dans le coin pour une rose allez
faites moi ça fait moins plaisir ans il
est là
le plus beau c'est mon père noël un
cadeau plus ou une boule de noël
diderot à ce que la guirlande qui va
avec non il ya une autre boule mais
celle là c'est mon jardin secret secret
d'un secret de tout ce même la boule
elle a disparu works est parti tu sais
quoi
il va rester avec le vendeur pour danser
avec teddy bout celui là je suis tout
émoustillé alors on y va de l'art
moderne
je pars toute la france allez on est fou
toute bonne tendance et c'est parti
entre tourner la tête aux berlinois toi
tu es un gym arts à l'e3
s
et ça ce n'est pas grave on a tout mais
je puisse moi ça tout est bidon
excuse moi aussi j'aurais pas droit par
hasard mon cadeau eh ben il est là ça va
être le petit vendeur pakistanais on
adore et quant à notre tout très vite
pour à nouveau numéro d'une de leurs
modèles c'est un bisou toi